[Music]
go pick your food
for an entire week i'm gonna let henry
choose our family's dinners
mushrooms
it looks fantastic
hi i'm hannah i'm the world's okay mom
and i have a very disorganized closet
hi i'm hannah i'm the world's okay mom
and you've seen me
have a lot of fun with my two older boys
they've gotten to choose my hair color
their meal plan mama yes they've meal
planned our weeks
and we've had a blast but you know what
it's time for henry to join in
so for an entire week i'm gonna let
henry choose our family's dinners
since henry's only one year old he isn't
the most
verbal he doesn't say many words so i
have a few techniques that i'm going to
try
to get some non-verbal choices from him
i don't know what to expect for this
week because we're kind of
playing it by ear we're going to figure
it out as we go and i'm just nervous
that he's going to pick
some sort of combination for dinner that
i can't pull off okay so we're each
going to pick a food
we're going to place him in the center
of the room and whoever he walks
to that's the food we're going to have
for dinner so what is your food wyatt
woods what's your pizza matt what's
yours
chinese chinese food mine is salmon
and salad are we ready here we go get in
the center baby
henry you love your mom
oh interference oh
got it henry ended up choosing wyatt
i actually love ribs so well you know
who's making them
yes now i've seen in past videos you've
left some comments saying that it looks
like i do all the cooking and so
that stuck with me i thought about it
and decided to do something differently
this day
let me know when they're done the ribs
were great i will give that to matt he
did a good job
these ribs aren't exactly as off-bone as
we usually
do but henry are you happy with your
dinner choice
that was his first rib ever and he just
got to chow down and he was
on cloud9 wyatt are you happy
[Music]
wow for someone who is so pro pizza
well pizza may be better than this i
will never say no to ribs
henry made a good choice day two i
decided to get a more
literal selection from henry i am going
to hold henry in front of the fridge and
whatever
he picks is the main ingredient for the
dish that i have to cook tonight
henry hey what are you gonna pick oh
no he pulled out feta cheese
which was much to jackson's
disappointment
typically with feta cheese i just use it
as a sprinkling on a salad
but i have seen this tick tock pasta
going around
for ages let's do it getting the water
boiling
in a shallow baking dish i had cherry
tomatoes feta
a bunch of seasonings and olive oil
let's pop this in the oven
it looks delicious yum
all right let's get this on our pasta
henry loves pasta he is a pasta fiend
yum yum everyone enjoyed it it was fine
the cheese doesn't have that much flavor
in it
really yeah not that much
this is some tomato sauce
i didn't know i raised a family of food
critics
it's pretty good it is a little bland
i shouldn't have done spaghetti it's not
the right pasta
for that type of sauce i also would do
more feta moving forward and maybe i
should have salted it on top of
the rest of my seasonings say night
night
nine nights blow kiss
yes
day three i decided to do something a
little more toy based
toy food i've chosen five
pizzas as options waffle
mushroom pizza
mushrooms chicken
and tomato it's almost like i paid him
to do it
i feel like he just sensed my vibes and
he knew what i wanted him to choose
to just really drive the kids crazy
[Music]
mushrooms
mushrooms are a hot topic in our house
they were previously jackson wyatt's
least favorite food of all time like the
thought the smell
the look the sound of the word mushrooms
made them gag
until i hid them in burgers one day
to try to get them used to the taste and
they decided they love them we're gonna
get our favorite local pioneer town
restaurant they make the best mushroom
tacos i've ever had in my
life red dog saloon is the best
restaurant i've had in a very long time
i'm
so excited and i really think the kids
will be stoked because the mushroom
tacos are delicious
and i don't have to cook tonight these
mushroom tacos
are the best tacos they're soft tacos
and they're folded over
yeah we're all ready
[Music]
more from goodness now i know i've done
some vegan content recently and
i am still sticking with trying to
choose more plant-based meals so these
mushroom tacos
that are one of my favorite foods also
just happen to be vegan why i cleaned
this plate
jackson cleaned his plate mushroom power
henry are you ready to eat your taco
it's got your whoops it's got your
tomato
yum
so good man i had just had a
conversation we were talking about how
his contribution to every video is
taking a bite
and chewing and saying um so good
now in honor of matt's contribution to
this series let's just have a quick
montage
it's good delicious it's really good
that's amazing
it's really good so excited it's so good
oh gourmet one day we'll do an episode
all about matt saying different words
day four we decided to go
all out and we took all of henry's food
toys and put them inside his play
enclosure and he had his pick of
so many food options pizza
jackson finally got his pizza we can all
rest easy
they are really good at making the
homemade pizza dough i have my
chef number one let me see you you look
great
for christmas their grandma their gigi
got them
chef hats and aprons so that they can
feel official while they help me in the
kitchen
you excited all right let's do this they
can mix the dough they can measure the
ingredients they can do all of it
come on chef you got this don't no
don't taste it that's just raw flour
that's what your apron is for wipe it on
your apron
wowza roll your sleeves up dude i don't
want
sweater in mine cooking with kids is not
easier you think that having help in the
kitchen makes it easier but they're
actually at the age where it's still a
little stressful for me but i try so
hard to take a step back let them leave
let them make the mess
let them experiment we have a chef on
our hands
kneading dough we're gonna oil this up
and cover it let it rise okay
we are rolling out the dough here wyatt
here's your piece here's the thing with
pizza i put it on the table
it disappears i literally put it on the
table
turn around to grab my camera turn back
and everyone has finished
they inhale this pizza henry himself is
a pizza crust fiend
so having his very own slice was a very
big deal to him
and we will definitely be making this
more day five i decided to take things
outside
and get a little bit more distance for
henry's choice
hey guys you want to come show what you
picked oh gosh i need something to prop
this up
okay i picked asparagus i picked donut
i picked the potato
i picked cheese okay ready let's go guys
picked a donut what is it with wyatt and
his gravitational pull
towards henry he won again
how am i going to cook dinner with a
donut
henry where are you sad he wants to walk
i'm sad he wants to walk around
now i have to make donut dinner i feel
like i'm on chopped
right now or like yeah like this is my
mystery basket
so i'm gonna make donut bread pudding
and hopefully stale up these donuts a
little bit more
in this bowl we got a little egg
evaporated milk
cinnamon nutmeg so we're gonna pour this
on top
what a weird dinner okay this is looking
amazing
i'm very pleased with the assortment of
donuts used
cause look at that chocolate sauce never
thought i'd look down at my plate and
see donuts
potato and asparagus but there's the
first time for everything
this is first donut oh my gosh are we
bad parents
oh my gosh his mind is blown
[Music]
tell me what you think about the donut
is it good it was fantastic it was
fantastic
wow that's good let's get that chewing
shot of you saying mmm
so good it's really good
so good and that came through with his
standard response
this is really good there we go that's
the mat we know and love
day six i decided to eliminate people
from the choice once again
and i took the toy food and i put it
outside and let henry pick his
ingredients go pick your food
whoa waffles
what is that one
oh egg he chose waffles and eggs you
know what that means
we're having breakfast for dinner here's
the catch with this food i don't have a
waffle maker
it's in storage so i had to pivot and i
used waffle
mix to make pancakes same thing
different shape
now here is a quick picky eater tip i do
this with my pancakes every time
if you have a picky eater at home you
can make them hulk pancakes
and you can either use blended spinach
or like a superfood
protein powder i like to use a spirulina
vitamin powder mix and i put it in my
pancake batter
and it makes green pancake it's really
exciting for the kids to eat them
you know what i'm making yay and they
feel like they're super heroes and
they're colorful
and fun and they're still getting
nutrients fried eggs
for the big kids you know it's so funny
how just a little switch
in the day like a little out of the box
idea can really make someone's day
and breakfast for dinner did just that
scrambled egg
pancake henry a breakfast king he loves
his pancake
[Music]
day seven threw me for a loop it was
a rollercoaster ride of a meal i have an
extensive list here
of different ingredients there's more
than just this page excuse my
messy handwriting but i'm gonna let him
i'm gonna
what am i gonna do i'm gonna put all of
these in a hat
and i'm gonna let him choose as many
ingredients as he wants
and that's what we're going to have to
make dinner out of okay hand me one
oh thank you honey good job
yeah the kids is great chicken
chicken bananas
that's his favorite food cola
okay cola banana chicken my first
thought when he pulled all three of
those out
is okay cola will be a drink alongside
a chicken dish that i make and then
maybe we'll have a fruit salad on the
side
but i stopped myself and i said you know
what hannah you are not being creative
enough
you're going so basic with these
ingredients come up with something
better
so i went back to the drawing board all
right i found a recipe for cola chicken
so i know cola
is used a lot of the time as a marinade
for beef dishes
i just wasn't sure if it worked for
chicken so i did a little research and
cola chicken is a thing it is very
common actually i just had never tried
it
so i have my cola chicken browning
i took cola soy sauce ketchup garlic
a little bit of brown sugar and pepper
and
made my own makeshift marinade for this
chicken
well this is a meal i never thought i'd
see on my stove
but you know what i'm embracing this
for the bananas i sprinkled them in a
little bit of sugar just so they would
brown and get a little crispy on the
ends
and i fried them in canola oil i've
never fried bananas before and i think i
probably did it wrong i probably should
have coated them in a flower or
something
but there's a first time for everything
and everything in the learning
experience
it looks fantastic
heck yeah cola chicken and wow
the reactions i got from my family when
they tasted this cola chicken
is it good is it wyatt approved
jackson wyatt loved it it was a really
really fantastic marinade for this
chicken
it tasted amazing
[Music]
oh my gosh huge fan this is like
one of my favorites so far matt
absolutely loved it
henry did you clean your plate did you
clean his plate
yes he loved it henry cleaned his plate
before i could even
see him eat it he was so happy with the
chicken
moment of truth
we've made so many weird foods on the
show at this point between the spaghetti
tacos
banana bread stuffing donut bread
pudding cola chicken
i feel like we almost should release a
cookbook of just
the bizarre foods my kids come up with
are you gonna stay
okay do you want to come here by me by
the end of the week
i was so pleased with henry's choices i
feel like he made us push our boundaries
in terms of
cuisine that we try ingredients that we
try
he picks something viral he picks
something wild he picks something sweet
he really had a great choice throughout
this entire week
would i do this again absolutely i think
it'll only get more fun the older he
gets
so if you have a baby at home let him
choose dinner
you never know what'll happen what was
your favorite food from the week that
henry picked
what dog red dog
the meal i didn't cook thanks
that's wyatt for you so that's all for
now
i'm hannah and what did you think about
the meals henry picked would you eat any
of them
and would you try this with your own
baby let me know on instagram
let me know if you have any more fun
food ideas for us to explore
and if you please excuse me we are on
our sixth walk of the day
and i gotta navigate this wagon till
next
[Music]
time
you